will that encourage you to do the myths
marvel the Muslim superhero we're doing
Captain Marvel right now Captain Marvel
shooting right now at brie Larson Miss
Marvel which is another character in the
comic books the Muslim hero who was
inspired by Captain Marvel is definitely
sort of in the works we have plans for
that once once we've introduced Captain
Marvel to the world I am so
disillusioned hey everybody it's Charlie
I got a lot of requests to do a video
about this miss Marvel teaser the Kevin
Feige drop like oh we have plans to
introduce her we're definitely gonna do
it after Captain Marvel so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
this is a black panther a giveaway
that's going on that I'll explain at the
end of the video but the big deal with
Miss Marvel is is that obviously you
can't do her till after you do Captain
Marvel because of the way she was
introduced in the comics and even though
they changed a lot of things they do try
to remain relatively true to comic book
origins she debuted right after Marvel's
big infinity event a couple years ago
what a coincidence that after infinity
war Kevin Feige is teasing that some of
the repercussions will be the
introduction of new Marvel heroes so
you're starting to see how they're using
the logic of the finger-snap to spin off
plot for other movies but I know there a
lot of questions about when she's gonna
appear whose movies is she going to
pop-up in how were they gonna use the
character in those movies because she's
in Jersey City spider-man for example is
in Queens on the other side of Manhattan
they both go to magnet schools the one
that Miss Marvel goes to in Jersey City
is called Cole's academic high school
the one that spider-man goes to
obviously Midtown high everybody knows
that that's in Forest Hills on the other
side of Manhattan like I said they're
separated by the island of Manhattan in
spider-man is mostly been involved with
all this big high-level Avengers stuff
miss Marvel feels more like a defender
street-level character so I'm expecting
them to use her in that way in these
other big Avengers movies it when I say
Avengers movies what I mean is is like
the Captain Marvel sequel or in a Spider
Man sequel she would show up I don't
expect them to introduce her overnight
and they just automatically make her an
Avenger it took spider-man a while to
work up to being knighted an Avenger by
Iron Man during infinity war so I should
actually say because I forgot to say it
earlier care
for spoilers from infinity war I feel
like this is one of the last weekends
that most people are waiting to go see
the movies so we should be clear of
spoiler territory within the next week
but a lot of you are like hey wait a
minute didn't they just cancel the
Inhumans TV show on ABC what does that
mean for miss Marvel because she's an
inhuman in the comics how are they gonna
weave that into her comic book backstory
in the MCU if they're not planning on
doing Inhumans the big thing about the
Inhumans is a film property is is that
way back when they first started phase 1
the whole idea of putting that movie on
the schedule like hey we're gonna be
doing an Inhumans movie down the road
was at the time people felt like it was
a strategic move against Fox because of
the way the Inhumans powers read they
feel a lot like mutants even though per
the comics they're not technically
mutants it's just a biological origin
for powers in the MCU thus far has
largely been technologically based
eventually what ended up happening is as
we get to this Disney Fox deal that
looks like it might happen by the end of
next year they're saying that the deal
was going to be completed by the end of
next summer that means that they can use
the term mutant inside the MCU they can
use any of those big characters that
they want so they have the biggest most
popular characters that have biological
powers like that why would they then
need to introduce the Inhumans unless
you wanted to do Black Bolt and include
him in the Illuminati if they end up
doing a movie like that and phase 4 even
if Kevin Feige wants to do some version
of them at some point it seems like
they're not a big priority for him just
given what's happened in the last year
so miss Marvel's origin would have to be
a little bit different now they could
give her her powers from Captain
Marvel's powers but that's not exactly
the way that it happened in the comics
she's just a big fan girl of Carol
Danvers then during Marvel's infinity
Black Bolt sets off a Terrigen bomb
because it's a big portion of the planet
to go through terrigenesis
miss Marvel has inhuman DNA so naturally
she goes to that process gets powers but
she has this vision of Carol Danvers
like a hallucination of her in the big
Tara Jean cloud so because she's a big
Carol Danvers fangirl she calls herself
Miss Marvel and makes a costume for
herself that's based on Miss Marvel's
classic comic book costume with the big
bolt down the middle so Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel wields cosmic power she
absorbs near infinite amounts of energy
and can read
she can go binary but Miss Marvel like I
said more of a defenders street-level
hero she can make parts of her body
bigger and more dense so it's like a
biological version of what ant-man does
when he becomes giant man only she has
more fine-tuned control of it so she can
just make her fists real big if she
wants she can make her legs really long
so she can step really far and travel
really fast or she could become as big
as a building maybe not quite as big as
ant-man like ant-man says that his limit
is 65 feet during the ant-man in the
wasp trailer I imagine miss Marvel would
be closer to like 30 feet they might
change that for the movies but it just
sounds like they'll wait - the Captain
Marvel sequel whenever that eventually
ends up happening we'll just assume that
it's happening for now depending on how
the first Captain Marvel movie goes and
then just have her pop up wherever she
feels like she fits best so what they've
done lately in Phase three and now going
into phase four is they do those team-up
movies like where they pair the Hulk
with Thor so they just find good
pairings like which two characters work
really well so my hope is is that for
the spider-man sequels Kevin Feige said
that we'd be doing the Harry Potter
thing following spider-man through high
school so if that holds up and they
reassigned their sharing arrangement
with Sony and we get a third spider-man
movie he's finishing high school in that
and they have some minor crossover with
Miss Marvel assuming that that movie
drops after the Captain Marvel sequel
wherein they might introduce that Miss
Marvel character because it does feel
like you have to wait for a Captain
Marvel movie to introduce the Miss
Marvel character then phase five phase
six whatever going forward depending on
how the character works out they can
just put her wherever they want and you
assume they start out with a younger
version of the character that's close to
spider-man's age so if you assume he's
about seventeen as of the events of the
finger-snap then in a couple years when
spider-man is heading into his third
sequel he'll be about eighteen you
introduced the Miss Marvel character in
the Captain Marvel sequel she's like 15
16 years old but beyond that Kevin Feige
hasn't said much about what they plan to
do with the character just expect them
to change her backstory the way they're
changing Carol Danvers backstory we'll
get more details about that soon even
though Marvel said that they're not
doing a comic-con panel that does not
mean that they won't drop a trailer so
there will be a lot of Marvel Avengers
for related stuff happening at the end
of the year I think they're just gonna
be kind of quiet about it during the
summer but here's a brief clip of Miss
Moore
in Avengers Assemble just to give you an
idea for how her powers work
[Music]
I do not want to die the vengers
Fay's paleri
stealing from crushing me please
this is so heavy
so let me know in the comments how do
you want them to introduce the Miss
Marvel character and if she's not gonna
be an inhuman how do you want her to get
her powers in which other movies do you
want to see her pop up and if she's
gonna be a relatively high school age
person
one of the younger MCU actors there is
that black panther blu-ray that's still
going on all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last big video Rus
Red Cloud I did talk about the
juggernaut and what they might be doing
with that character in my last big
Deadpool video so you can check that out
click here for that then click here for
more Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]